hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to slay away camp now
we're on our second movie of what could
possibly be literally dozens of movies
here but I have to play this game
against cuz it's it's so fun not for
like the game itself everything
surrounding the game like the gameplay
is simplistic and it's just about
blowing up oh oh oh it's just about
everything else in it
[Music]
fling this that's the sound effect for a
chainsaw dance fling not even flung not
even shook oh jeez sorry sorry alright
danger lake just like everything else
about this game combining into an
experience god what the [ __ ] is wrong
and they talking about experiences like
as if I know anything about it you gotta
go into the lake ah
did he drown was that drowning oh oh oh
God
why can't they swim they have bathing
suits we're gonna be swim oh geez oh I'm
sorry apparently that was amazing no
right to remain deadly oh oh how the
oh I can't attack him from the front
that girl is high it hello Kate
sorry I had to do it had to do it right
now how do I get out of here because ah
I I done bad okay let me back off Oh
what I gotta do here is come at her from
the other side
ha ha Bisky sorry about that Oh heaven
but sorry excuse me
Judas that guy just died
oh ok apparently that doesn't cut
someone's head off but me punching
someone in the back of that is enough
triple truncheon alrighty then
kid you are still not safe how do i oh
oh now the puzzles are starting to get a
bit more complicated so how
oh I can slide past him that's right
haha you should have been paying
attention there bub oh maybe do oh god I
gotta unlock all and then their dad for
some reason I guess entering them oh I
guess entering the demon portal just
causes everyone to explode from the
residual energy no not trip to phobia
trippa phobia not trip of phobia oh good
fear of holes god I actually
legitimately have triple phobia yeah oh
sorry about that
I'm owned though I can't do that
okay so oh you can't go anywhere what
you're scared
okay I got it
how about bump up hot up up you look so
happy over there and yet you're going to
be so dead if only I could figure out
where to go from here
well I'm lost han yeah I got this I'm
smart enough for this hip hip hip hip
hip hip hip ah there we go now I got it
we're all in the right order now and
you're dead and I'm sorry hi I apologize
for nothing do I have a backstory on
this guy - oh God
Oh God oh no it's just look look oh jeez
okay let me is lightened a little bit
because they're just box fingers it's
like less than Minecraft graphics here
all right so there's got to be a special
way to go about this because apparently
can't be just as easy as me going up
there because that ended in death
wouldn't it but if I were to go some
other way I might be able to count
Wampus the one people yep haha got ya so
then I I want beside you that means that
I could whomp a Phi you with the
headbutt from hell
ha Buki ah got it
nailed it and you're dead for some
reason you're not even emotional about
Schrute turkey I must be growing less
and less heartless because I don't feel
any remorse for any of these death cabin
crush
that's not nice not nice at all oh geez
is that their eyes then their eyes just
roll out on the floor I mean it was only
a 2d representation of eyes but even so
okay splatter delicious forest frenzy
finish in seven turns let it off I can
let it of a whoo-whoo boo boo boo man oh
oh just oh I did all right I need to
stop freaking out about these deaths
because the whole game is just gonna be
nonstop this if I keep freaking out not
gonna be able to get anywhere in my my
life here
all right bookcase bullies you got it
it's knock that one over Oh with pop Oh
Boop
how about oh sorry sir how about ski
okay so I got to get back over yonder
who's um's just sing it off but there we
go got it okay habilis okay everyone's
dead now can I go home have a good time
to go oh but what happens if I miss hey
they live and everyone's happy except
for me the murderer who wanted to kill
it buddy hot springs having Ono is this
gonna be another case with these kids
somehow mysteriously don't know how to
swim
I'm just operating under the base
assumption - defecation good there's so
job what why does that kill them I don't
get they came here to swim those like
their main purpose how are they dying
from falling in water swimming hole
horrors key oh no I'm gonna I'm gonna
kill somebody with a porta potti
oh I'm about to kill someone with a
porta potti Kinect oh oh but I can't get
to the exit if I do that so I have to I
have to cease the murder licious urge to
kill someone with a porta potti I have
to try to not Oh what have you done
you killed your friend okay so that's
not the correct move what I brat this is
how does he all right so now I'm gonna
get back Faria Halicki sorry hat dude oh
I can't do that no but they're gonna run
oh so I need to I need to stop the
portal body from being pushed over gross
then I need to come up here ha ha your
dad yeah sorry about that
that happened then I can go I got it
with my brain
you got it in your brain / the teens
before the SWAT team arrives finishing
six turds
oh man that's a lot to kill all right
let him up to a challenge so if I run
away Oh run away that wasn't the right
way to run I did not do this correctly
do that is it gonna be like oh it's
gonna be like a chain reaction you run
you got murder scares you Oh murder
scares you you're all so stupid and now
you're dead how do I get back there in
two turns yeah so yeah that's the
question why why is this guy not scared
by me getting near him there and this
won't do cuz he'll run the wrong way oh
wait you mean the correct way to solve
it isn't to do the chain reaction of
Spooks into the fire but that's such a
cool way to do it
oh man I thought that was gonna be it
hey sorry alright I guess I'm guessing
group Oh final scene please make it stop
[Music]
Oh No Oh No hahahahaha
/ the cute little bunny the cute little
bunny is so happy about the music it's
good probably not that good but it's
it's alright oh boy I did cowboy huh I'm
asking
well I guess I'm not a fan of you Oh
silence Wow
that just goes to show you don't don't
go into the middle of the woods singing
about friendship cuz obviously I do not
want anything to do with our friendship
another return to slay away camp lay
away camp 2.5 oh my god I love this and
there's so much to do in it it's awesome
see flat-faced origami rune party's over
bin cushioned the sink of the sleigh Oh
huffed up Oh God leaf blower is a
creative killing oh god I kind of want
it but I'm not ready for that
emotionally or anyway urban skull face
poorly received urban skull face revamp
from the Shelf slay away camp 12 skulls
into hood oh geez okay so anyway that is
all I'm gonna play about this game I
don't think I'm gonna do a full
playthrough there just because I
eventually get tired of the puzzles and
then you guys would you know
watch me be slowly be more and more
terrible at throughout the game but this
game is fun like legitimately it has
charm it is like gameplay to it it's got
puzzles and it's got other elements on
top of it and I really like that so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought it's down
in the comments below and as always I'll
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]